the 90s was also the decade that
discovered our girl Avril Lavigne now
the 34 year old is back with new music
it was partially inspired by a very dark
time in her life a Burroughs long and
very serious battle with Lyme disease
I felt like I was dying and I was like
accepted it got keep my head writing
head above water they wrote it from my
bed in the middle of fighting for my
life
Avro was diagnosed with the disease in
2014 after feeling achy and fatigued
she says the struggle to regain her
health is reflected in her first album
in over five years you know the past and
life was like boy Bashi and a leg angsty
like I tried to challenge myself on this
album 2002 is complicated turn a burl
into pops reigning princess when she was
just 17 years old she followed it up
with a string of hits but before all
that Avro found inspiration in another
famous singer Shania Twain who
coincidentally also faced her own battle
with Lyme disease you told her Shania
I'm gonna be a famous singer this 14
years old there's a contest submit a
tape of a tape of yourself yes I won and
aim at Shania and sang on stage with her
it probably just felt like home it like
so right Vinny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]